all right we have yet another GOP
Presidential hopeful speaking of
embarrassing
um taking Disney's side against Ron
DeSantis and this time it's Mike Pence
unfortunately let's listen to that
I just don't believe it's it's in the
interest of the people of any state for
a a government to essentially go after a
business that they disagreed with on a
political issue I disagree with Florida
moving against uh Walt Disney I disagree
with California moving against Walgreens
because they're going to obey the law
about a board of patience in some 20
States so they're going to cancel 120
million dollar project look at the end
of the day the business of America is
business and and I'm not terribly
surprised to see Disney canceling a
billion dollar contract it's only that's
only going to harm people in the Orlando
and Florida area and and it's one more
reason why uh as a limited government
conservative uh I've said for months now
that I I think both sides ought to stand
down take the victory for parents rights
in the legislature and move on
um pathetic pathetic and and this is now
so we got Mike Pence Nikki Haley uh I I
believe Vivek ramaswamy
and of course Donald Trump have all
taken the side of Disney the Disney
groomers against Ron DeSantis
um and it is pitiful
you know we hear from Mike Pence that oh
it's going to harm the people of Florida
if Disney isn't there if we don't
capitulate to Disney and allow them to
sexualize our kids it's going to harm
the people before well how does it harm
the people of Florida how does it harm
uh children all across the country
to have Disney
um sexualizing children
and supporting things like you know the
castration and mutilation of kids
and supporting things like pornographic
content in elementary schools which is
where this all began
Deb is that that's what that's what
Florida was trying to get rid of in
elementary schools and Disney came out
against them
um on that
using all of their
enormous wealth and power and influence
to um support again the sexualization
corruption abuse and mutilation of kids
so is that what's a bigger harm Mike
what's more harmful to the country
to have Disney engaging in this kind of
behavior
and attacking children
um
or
there to be some kind of consequence for
that to actually push back against it
did you know that our friends at genucel
have upgraded their most popular package
to feature their top selling deep
firming vitamin C serum plus Ultra
retinal moisturizer with natural retinal
alternative I bet you didn't know that
but now you do right now you can take
advantage of this limited time package
for 70 percent off why waste time and
money to go get work done on your face
when you can get genucel skin care
shipped right to your door genocide
secret is a family recipe for over 20
years that makes it safe for all skin
types and perfect for both men and women
made by a compounding pharmacist in
small batches and is always safe cruelty
free and natural you know my hair and
makeup artist Cherokee is a lot like a
lizard any chance she gets she'll be out
laying on a rock sunbathing in the
middle of a desert somewhere but to make
sure she doesn't have skin that looks as
cracked and Dusty as the desert ground
she uses genucel's wide range of
products to keep her skin looking young
go to
geniusell.com's most popular package for
70 off featuring genuine cells Ultra
retinal and genucel's Firming Serum as
well get a complimentary Spa Essentials
box with every package order plus a free
upgrade to priority shipping you can get
all of that you can get it now but you
got to go to genucel.com Walsh that's
genucel.com Walsh
it is uh it's
absolutely pathetic and I we shouldn't
have to explain
why I mean especially if you and this is
why not that I'm surprised but from
pence in particular it's especially
disappointing because his kind of brand
is to be a social conservative someone
who understands why the culture matters
Well you aren't going to make any
progress in the culture
when when you know we say a corporation
like Disney is what off limits
because they provide a lot of jobs
you know if there's if there's a lot of
money and a lot of jobs to be um
to be found
in the business of sexualizing kids well
that's that's a problem that needs to be
fixed
and we're not going to fix it as long as
the Republican party is held hostage by
corporate interests
corporate interests who already hate
them they already hate you Disney
already hated Ron DeSantis and every
Republican
they hate you Mike Pence
okay
and they're working against you and
everything that you say you believe
so
you come out and defend them and what do
you get in exchange for that you don't
even get anything for I mean at least if
I thought that by Pence and Haley and
the rest of them coming out of Defending
Disney that Disney that's just because
Disney is going to donate to their
campaigns or something that would make
it okay but at least on a on a
self-serving level I could understand it
it would still be pathetic and cowardly
but then you kind of know why they're
doing it oh well you're selling out from
for the money well okay yes a billion
other people have done that everyone in
politics does it doesn't make it okay
but in this case it's all the more
pitiful
because they're it's that's not gonna
happen
you're not gonna benefit from it
directly
they are not going to return the favor
okay so these woke corporate interests
that you are slavishly
um
kowtowing to they are not going to
return the favor Disney's not going to
come out and defend Mike Pence
that ain't gonna happen
so for you might as well
go to war with them you might as well
push back
you you literally have nothing to lose
that's the thing conservatives need to
understand but it's like
you have we have nothing to lose
and actually fighting back against
corporate wokism
yeah we're going to anger we're going to
anger the corporations they're not going
to like us that's already the case
they already hate us we just we the
target okay is building business with a
an apparel company that sells satanic
merchandise they hate us already
for this portion of the shows move over
to the members block hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
have a great day Godspeed